this is you know supposed to be on a
middle game I think this lecture but
we're gonna focus it's very exciting
time here it's the chess olympiad going
on so we're going to focus on the how
the US team is doing and I prepare two
games to show you from today's around
and of course uses a middle game ideas
in this as well but a particular we'll
see this two important victories the
first game I have for you is from the
match United States vs Serbia today
Serbia is you know solid team they had
four strong grandmasters so us was the
favorite to win and they did they got
the job done with three out of three
three two one good score there were a
couple of scary moments Fabiano Khurana
was lost several occasions today but
managed to draw after a blundering upon
and Ray Robson unfortunately was almost
winning without a pawn and just
something happen and it just blundered
and took a draw but we did win two games
and that's why the score is three to one
for the US team's first game is Hikaru
Nakamura against a solid opponent mark
bouche Robert 2662 I mean that's a very
very very high rating so when you're
facing somebody like that even though he
car was favorite with white but there is
no guarantee in fact this game was
decided by one blunder you'll see so we
have Sicilian defense d6
before okay
takes 90 for a six-night we should be
three Bishop c5 attacking the knight so
we have Sicilian defense opening and
this is a very interesting system block
seems like losing a temper but now just
get some kind of a dynamic position so
hire any players they like to play these
positions because it offers winning
chances here so Quincy Forge I took out
this would you like what to block did in
this game see
Vogler's wasting little bit of temples
now goes back 97 this is all standard
win ce7 be 6 inch 5 the point of h5 is
if Knight f6 is played then you're going
to have to deal with the move like
Bishop h6 and I think that's what Marcus
was worried about and then his King is
stuck so he didn't want that to happen
so he played h5 first from the moment it
looks like he's playing really risky but
it's again it's very dynamic opening you
can just take advantage of it right away
so f4 by Hikaru obviously wants to do
some kind of break but now Marcus goes
here and some 94 ideas are not coming so
they should be 4 by Nakamura castles
simply castles now and basically you
know trying to see now what is what is
why it can until here you know and he
got to play that five very dramatic and
important move because if it doesn't
play a five it should be seven comes in
95 black is more or less okay 95 this is
a typical idea for Sicilian defense when
you play fr you're going to be
encountered by the 9500 okay so that's a
standard idea to remember yes black bed
move because now after this move you
will go Bishop e3 and then strategically
now you create a huge weakness here and
then he can take Bishop c4 check this
square is designed for the night
everybody remember in this kind of
positions if you put a pawn on e5 you're
going to be clearly worse you don't have
to
okay you want the night your night storm
only five that's what you want to do
okay
he took Marcus took h3 I could really
feel the disappointment for a black
because he is playing very distant now
he goes back night ft-7 defending the
night only five the night only five is
the sole of the blacks position here
okay without this night his position
will fall apart
instantly Brooke a fade Bishop f8 again
it looks like little loose but no
concrete way to take advantage of it
Queenie tree they should be 792 Hikaru
is trying to transfer the knight on a 40
we did and now it's amazing position his
opponent should have just played Bishop
h6 pinning this Knight and the car
probably is going to go feed you to the
skin h7 and position is roughly equal
here you know maybe what is tiny bit
better but it's hard to say no concrete
way to break through whatsoever so
that's a black is more or less okay here
but his opponent plays queen g6 can you
spot the winning move here for Nakamura
after this move his opponent was so
disappointed that he simply resigned one
move blunder at the very high level of
no Olympics here but what is this
blunder here let's see who can find idea
here to take advantage of it
Mario excellent his opponent resigned
why well he has to take if it doesn't
take his respect resigning his lipid and
I wouldn't resign especially in the team
event you never want to resign and let
your team down you know you won't even
if you completely lost you play until
it's evidently not resigning it's a bad
idea in a team event like that now what
did he Caro had in mind
don't rush when you see a good move you
do what think for a better one right a
man will ask it remem death now what is
the better move here that is going to
force force the winner basically wait
raise your hand who is saying a move
raise your hand please okay yes Queen g3
putting pressure on the night and night
now how could they put a 95 doesn't do
the task right because we eliminate and
we pick up the night if it goes to have
seven we go rook f1 check so not so
Clara what's going to happen with this
piece so King h7 and what is the
crushing idea if King h7 comes in
this is probably what mark cush missed
here yes excellent job opening up the
light square bishop and now this
attacker comes in into the game now he
takes bishop takes all right it's very
nice you know USA was up by one in this
you know what expected to be a very
tough game but the karo proved again is
a value for the US team by scoring this
nice victory and giving the lid now this
right now Olympics they played five
rounds so far there are three teams
leading at the moment it's Ukraine by
the way Ukrainian team is playing the
best so far they've defeated Russia and
China already Wow
so they are so next round Ukraine is
face facing us US team so that's day
after tomorrow tomorrow players will
take a rest day and the other teams are
doing really well is Netherlands
and India they both have a perfect score
five matches five victories so this is
going to be a big magic us is for weak
Tories and one draw so they're doing
well they are tied for fourth place
right now but with a huge match going on
on Thursday and it could really change
it obvious or five players on tip so
Trey Robson and same Champlin so and the
good thing is the US team is doing well
they haven't lost any game out of all
this twenty games they played so
hopefully that would continue all right
now let's see if you remember this game
and find all the moves do the review
okay let's go pinky
and now it is a six this setup here now
Castle v6 now 24 G 622 97
a four
preventing some advances h5 again
because this this runs into [ __ ] so
that's why so h5 interesting move f4 and
I have six 1394 cost of safety if not f5
is necessary here
95
uh-huh
and now night f.2d 7 protecting the
night only 5 this is an excellent way to
protect the night takes takes
94 and here yeah I mean after [ __ ] page
six it would have been a big fight you
know very normal position big fight and
I mean probably Hikaru is too maybe a
little bit better nuts but not clear at
all but I mean this which page six this
is how the game developed basically it
would have won and here I don't see any
concrete way for black for white you do
anything but it's you know a little bit
better for him but unfortunately for
black and he went here and good news
wood for the US team what's the winning
idea
beautiful beautiful tactical shot by
Hikaru he is not going to miss this and
now after this move his opponent was
just so disappointed and perhaps upset
that he's simply resigned again decision
that I wouldn't be happy if I was the
coach because you could have still fight
fight until then especially in the team
tournaments you never resign I mean pawn
is yeah I know the position is probably
lost but I mean it still has to win this
I mean here okay it's it's a pot yeah
it's not ideal it's not it's not pretty
but it's only upon yet so you just it's
more like he disappointed he was he was
just frustrated that's why he resigned I
mean I mean it was not quite reasonable
okay this was the game by he cards so he
brought us the +1 and now but this game
was actually beautiful so even even
better game I think this one was by
thusly soul crushing victory against
Grandmaster Nikolas said lock it said
lock is a very solid player it's got
this solid openings that he plays so
they put it this on Wesley okay Wesley
is 250 points almost higher than his
opponent but again he's playing a Grand
Master with black you know so it's no
like hey let's league going win it's not
going to be like that okay it's not easy
so here here to work very hard because
his opponent is playing very solid as
you can see it's putting some solid
college system look at that how solid
white position is
so they played this way and b6 aiming
for some 95 is a very important move
here wife to play this but his opponent
didn't want that so you're just playing
really solidly but should be seven rook
t1 rook e8 now black is preparing to
play e5 his opponent place now the move
himself
yeah so let's put in a training yeah II
five now you don't want to the trick is
to play e5 it's a problem right if you
take I mean this is not ideal because he
takes night and it's going to be a lot
of simplifications and your queen is
misplaced too so not so good
so this a four idea how should Wesley
handle this how should he play here very
important move it out and rush Bishop
f8e five yeah but we will pass a fear
that would be very passive we don't want
to take his bishop because he takes hg
then he opens up the H files we don't
really want that to happen
Secor but see for the special group and
c2 and that actually locks the position
that's a positional error because it
goes Bishop c2 and then it's got a five
and everything don't want to completely
lock the position here we need to defend
against the threat of a five okay
unfortunately c4 you just go to the ship
C - that doesn't help yet
if you take on before remember I told
you the bill did practically not papa
that's a four-track - ok you have to
watch our when upon us you you always
watch out for if I've idea ok so what
did he play here huh strong play by
Presley saw 97 focus focus to lose the
bishop yes no no with that rook opening
up Latif very risky if you open up this
h-file very risky
there could be consequences ok hope
you're getting mated perhaps take take
ePHI bish page 7 very very risky stuff
ok so you don't want that and you just
played like Wesley so perfect Bishop e7
excellent decision now CD is already
threatened so he has to do something he
plays here he 5 now what did invest it
was to do here to passive to passive 97
yes absolutely not h5 bishop is a bishop
and he wants to get that dad's
permission to at least have the pair of
the bishops a3 by GM said lock he again
wants you to take so now G seats by
Leslie so being patient not rushing
because that bishop is not going
anywhere so he's not in hurry to capture
the bishop because if you capture them
he is going to take back if you take
here mistake because now he takes attack
this guy and there could be some
potential problems here okay for you
so g6 9 f 1 he wants to bring the knight
to e3 f5
aggressive but perhaps unnecessary move
because otherwise night goes on a three
night goes on G for a lot of holes a lot
of weaknesses okay so now if night goes
only 3 F 4 is strong so takes Bishop f6
now if Wesley can manage taken 25 you
will be very happy here but 93 comes in
white is also bringing his pieces
towards the center yes because he wants
to fight for the e5 square in this
position it's a battle battle for the e5
square remember ok Knight e3 now what's
the idea 93 because he wants to castle
and he also wants to go Knight g4 and
545 squad now he is an excellent ok
he wants a canal g4 and here d5 trying
to fight for the center excellently de
95 Knight XE 593 ah he decided that he
should eliminate the Bishop and obtain
this position with two bishops looks
like black played excellently he has the
center and two bishops and he can go
Queenie 7 put the rook in I I really
like what he did so far I think he has
an advantage here Bishop c4 doe pinning
it see he is pinning him b5 look at that
his Bishop takes b5 Queen b6 very
aggressive play and white castles okay
white is up a pawn here black still has
to prove where is the compensation King
g7 Bishop d3 goes back
Bishop c5 black is putting a lot of
pressure
I mean objectively speaking I think why
it was probably okay in some point here
it's up opponent but but the pressure
pressure is huge here so now what is the
idea here after Bishop g5 excuse me
uh hi it looks do you think this grand
masters were blunder a fortune the
simple fork know the movies see Forge
look at that pressure now you take here
check and take okay two bishops are
going to be very very powerful in this
position so he played see for himself
what he's trying to do he is trying to
force d5 something like ninety five I
mean look at this I mean this guy is a
very clever player and if you take the
Queen he takes here and now this rook is
saying in this rookie saying White is
actually winning in his life so he is
trying to simply blockade this this was
pieces so but he says let's go anyway
now this before is very strong so he has
to take and now what is the idea for
black hair pink
he's downloaded the two pounds and white
if white moves the Queen he will be safe
here so this moment this is a very
important moment here okay well it's
black to play yes if it's your turn you
play 94 but it's my turn the rook takes
c3 fantastic sacrifice you will see now
why I say fantastic and now look at the
smoke what is the idea here
check he has to go rook f2 because
otherwise he could get mated on H file
he not so you went here and now c4
vested sacrifices another pawn his
opponent takes it he's up a exchange and
2 pounds now he puts pressure on him
with Luka fake group DF 8 now this is
the crucial moment here it looks like
white is just going to defend I mean how
can white really make progress here
b3 even computers are puzzled at the
moment here they're showing zero zero
zero they're showing that in the zeroes
here black enemy progress but that's the
saw had a plan let's see if you can find
that plan
black to play you need to find a winning
continuation so you have this deadly pin
sort of that he cannot really escape
from Bishop takes up two cupcakes I have
enough defenders on f2 that's the
problem
Graham age five correct but what's the
plan de that's when we play yes so he
plays h5 with idea H for his opponent
pushed upon H for threatening to take on
g3 he's one attacking h1 which is a
losing move but if he goes here now the
winning idea is
look at that pin look at that
unstoppable made here from here or from
here that's an amazing position huh
complete domination here and completely
weakening the position of opponents King
and if it takes on h4 what is the idea
when I for keeping the pressure on d7
cooking g3 I'm sorry the rectangle a
killer
who in g2 mate that cannot be prevented
properly if he goes here then simply
take the rock
so that's slightly winning the rook and
the game
I mean his opponent realize he's just
losing sleep taking each one and now yes
yes
well I have Queen h4 as well here in
each three ayah of course of course
beautiful beautiful idea look at that
mate that's the power of the bishops for
you right there that the P shirts are
too powerful in an open board like this
they're so strong so it's a part of a
king h1 and now take take and now very
important not to blunder here because if
you take Queen e7 check and suddenly
you're gonna you know you're gonna get
he was going to give you a lot of a lot
of checks so what did he have in mind
hg of course threatening checkmate on h4
okay
checkmate on a short is very powerful so
you can check now King age six and now
his opponent resigned because he doesn't
have a way to prevent this check
fantastic victory I think by Wesley so
he is in good form along with he car
they've a lot of points they've got a
lot of victory Sergey the other guys are
also at a score so we just need the
other teammates to improve a little bit
too if they play live it better then we
have excellent chances I think yes all
right so let's review this game this was
only 32 or 33 moves again not an easy
task
black against a solid GM you will the
lower rated and you have to try to win
because you have to try to press okay
how did he do that
v6
v6 Queeny - so it's the interesting fun
I kind of like this idea it'd look kind
of interesting we need to look t1 and
he's just preparing to play E 4 E 4 we
had a little bit of hard time here
because this is tricky position here and
it's not so easy here to find the right
continuation yes
Bishop e7 he's got it perfect raise your
hand please b5 now the night is under
attack
yes okay a3 and now see a lot of players
with the rush to take the bishop but you
don't want to do that okay
you don't want to rush it okay g6 simply
he goes here f5 Bravo
yeah threatening some f4 ideas see he's
trying to open up the position timing is
very important here because if you play
slow and hesitant it's not going to be
very good so timing is very very
important here okay so please remember
that ticks
try to open the center
now interesting he could take what the
bishop but he Bishop takes I think a
white can just Castle so he just wanted
to get a bishop here take and now it
looks like it really from the first
glance it looks like black is doing
really really well I think he is doing
extremely well theater in fact maybe
what vested it was a little bit risky
but he he felt the the need and the
necessity to go for it perhaps you know
I mean this be fine move it's certainly
it's a little bit you know I mean
sacrificing the full pawn here I guess
just this penis may be annoying so I'm
just trying to understand it Queen b6
luggages castles and then Queen comes to
f3 okay he can always play this way and
have a small advantage probably but they
probably wanted more okay will be six
castle changes seven
you should see fire
age five this one was amazing yeah it
looked like his again I was watching a
lot it computer was showing all all 0s
right you know but when you let it run a
little bit
he realized that there's no way to
actually do anything here white actually
doesn't have any any way to stop his
idea because this pin is a very very
deadly the spin on f24
take nhg again don't rush and take the
route because Queenie 7 check is coming
up and it least going to be a job so so
a US team has four wins so far and one
draw only again Czech Republic that was
a little bit disappointing yesterday US
was out raiding their opponents by a big
big margin but unfortunately they could
not score anywhere less this was
extremely close in fact had he won that
game he would have been on a perfect
score
so unfortunately Leslie didn't win that
position he had some promising chances
so that's the only draw against Czech
Republic so so far solid performance by
the US team so I think the match on
Thursday is going to kind of tell us
where things stand you know you know win
would be fantastic draw is was going to
be probably acceptable result but still
I think we're going as a favorites with
this lineup it's just we have to make
sure karana is playing his best so I
expect we're going to see the three top
guys plain karana Wesley Hikaru and
vastly and then and then coach will have
to decide who is going to put on a board
for against Ukraine Ukraine is doing
very strong about four and three
valo kitten and crib Orozco has been
scoring opponent victories so it's very
important we're solid on board for and I
think the color allocation is going to
be we are white on one and three so we
are black on two and four so usually
this kind of close matchups you try to
hold the black color and try to press
with white okay that's usually the game
plan so the implant will be to try to
have Leslie score a win and Caruana
please put pressure on Pahlavi on ovals
be really super for the Ukrainian team
so far so but I think looking at the
lineup I think Leslie I like West's
chances with white against anybody they
put in front of
so I think either it's going to be
critical or coral both so either we're
in Wesley has good chances that Nick
requests his best rest we can we can
probably win and other boards we just
need to be solid make sure they're solid
on board for so the way will be great
draw it's going to be alright but again
to win this Olympiad you can only lose
three points so we already lost one
point to win it usually you need
basically you need eight wins and three
draws or one last nine wins and a draw
so you really have a margin of three
points that you can lose if you lose one
match that's two points if you draw one
match that's already one point so even
though it seems like it's early to talk
about it but I've been to several
Olympians and I know how important each
match is important moment one mistake
could be very costly one mistake and you
lose a crucial match it happened to us
in 2012 we were tied for first two
rounds to go we were tied for first with
Russia China US and but we lost to China
in a very close match which should have
been drawn two to one blunder one one of
my teammates you know great player but
just made one blunder and then we were
out we want the last match but still we
could not medal so that's how close this
Olympians are and margin of error even
though you think it's 11 rounds and you
have a you know you don't really have if
you want to be the champion you have to
be really precise in Ukraine Ukraine has
been really impressive so far despite
the fact that they don't even have an
event choked in their team even Chuck is
not playing one of their big stars I
mean they have a really strong team very
balanced team they were not that up
seeds but they like I think fifth or
sixth by ranking so but I think they
were very balanced team stay there
interesting yes so you only have one
reserves so I think we'll see our top
three guys going in and you know I don't
know how they probably I'm thinking I
don't know exactly who they put
but we just need to be solid with block
okay so maybe they put some blonde is
pretty solid I mean little bit shaky so
far in one game in this tournament but
but overall is incredibly solid player
option is being a very solid tool so far
so again we haven't lost the game that's
already great if we don't lose any
individual games from four top players
eventually we're going to score some
victory somewhere okay and again at the
moment we need to in half margin is 20
half is perfect
two and a half it's fine we don't need
to go for three and a half or three one
victory so each match now is gonna be
crucial because now it's going to be
some tough opponents we're going to face
I'll just mention also how the woman
team is doing because at the same time
women team is playing in Olympia women
Olympiad is a little bit different
they usually have about five six teams
that they fight for the medals not too
many so it's usually China top team
favorites Russia Ukraine Georgia these
are the two for very strong teams okay
that they can really win this and then
there's some other teams us's the next
team strong I think Poland there's a
strong team but they're not that many
teams that I have four very strong
female players the US team is after I
think a good start they've had a couple
of shaky moments but they only lost one
match to Ukraine at one of the top teams
I mentioned two very close match two and
half to one and a half and they want
their other four matches so for another
round they're going to play a little bit
easier team they playing Turkey their
favorites to win so they sitting on
eight points out of ten in a contention
so China dropped a point already
they drew Philippines Georgia
unexpectedly lost no I think China drew
Vietnam and Georgia lost to Philippines
so the top teams have been dropping some
points right now in the clear lead we
have Ukraine and Russia and it's
followed by China and Georgia in u.s. so
us should try to win this easier matches
and then try to do well when they play
the head
they're going to have to face China
they'd have to face Russia and Georgia
if they're going to be in a medal
contention those are going to be tough
matches because that's when the US team
is going to be all rated you know
because the other teams have stronger
players high-rent but I think we have
some good coaching there the answer SATA
one is there as the team captain robert
has of the coach so we have some really
good coaching staff there so I think
they can try maybe to make you know some
strategies some special preparation for
this match it so everything is possible
so both teams are doing well and I think
the next end of this week and beginning
of next going to be very exciting to see
this is like a biggest event in every
every two years so both teams are in
contention for a medal okay at the end I
would like to assure you let's see study
okay all right if you won't study a kid
can do not study yes white to play and
draw we have done a similar study in
other side of the board I'm sure you
will remember the other one but this
absolutely beautiful study white to play
and drop
this is not easy it's very long solution
yeah the first one is very important I
mean if you think it's the same thing
you'll be yoga mistaken the first one is
very important okay
the problem here it seems like we are
lost because how are we going to stop
that past bond that's like a touchdown
right push push push and he's going to
get a queen how are we going to stop
that okay so we have a student here who
is very eager to answer okay what's this
personal Bravo
King V so now you want to catch him
catch him right boom boom you going to
catch the pond so this would have been a
mistaken idea
oops this would have been a mistake
because boom and you're not getting in
and then he pushes the pond
so King be seven he has to push King c7
I push push
it seems like what is she doing I mean
I'm pointing here what is sure she can
do it funds uh-huh a for yes I win
no look at that yeah oh yeah
yes I don't rush don't rush b5 correct
yes
now if check you're going to go before
and if it goes here now pay for that's
it takes still mate
absolutely so the important part is and
by the way here if I played b6 check
what are you gonna do huh King g6 I win
don't rush it why are you rushing us you
go back same system same mechanism okay
lock yourself in okay lock it in very
important because otherwise I go clean
it me King is on the way exactly
my King is on the way absolutely the
only way to stop to stalemate is to
break win ce6 but the neck is we take
and we win it so it's not a good idea
all right so this is another self stupid
idea for you to remember okay King d7 is
very important to start with okay you
really need to start with this move
otherwise you're going to lose this game
because he simply is simply going to
push his pawns okay so that's why we
don't want that to happen
okay one more so we got this one okay
let's see focus focus everybody why to
play and win okay I am going to need to
bring a special book next time because
you are you know all the all my puzzles
now bring that book on Thursday the old
book okay but let's give chance let's
give a chance to others okay white to
play and win a very unusual metal here
we're going to use to win this game very
unusual way we're gonna win this how ok
we need to win the pawn right guys how
are we going to try to win the pawn
what's the method we can use here we
have two methods right which methods we
have we're going to attack the phone
right so how
okay explain to us why King b-1a not
King City I wanna looking c3 like many
people right
a3 correct
now sacrificing the pawn and getting the
side pawn and then simply facing it
facing it that's it okay so that's why I
three he takes you just go there okay
but if you play king b1 now you're gonna
go King a2 so if he comes up here what
do we do he comes up here he comes up
here
easy take the pawn right he comes here
now opposition whoever has the
opposition he's gonna be winning this
game remember that yeah how about this
take my pond take my pond I'm happy to
give you my pond huh before
let's see now he said before I go here
he said before now look what's gonna
happen guys and now he threw away the
win with one quick move you could throw
away we'll be careful in King kept on
engines be very careful okay one mistake
that will be very costly exactly that
before school is designed for the king
in this position so the winning move is
indeed excellent he comes here he comes
here
excellent and we are getting the a
position excellent excellent job well
thanks everyone for attending this class
and hope to see you on Thursday and
hopefully we have some great results and
we can show some great games from that
matchup
USA vs. Ukraine that's going to be our
topic we'll talk about that see you see
you then